I'm discovering correction I'm
rediscovering that new element I believe
Lucent landscaping the shrubbery the
trees parking lots exits entrances
structure the protons and the neutrons
using the pavilions everyone
you
this implies a theoretical animal not
currently found on the periodic table I
think I will run a simulation to check
in on the viability yeah listen you have
a ball with that I know it's gonna work
miss take a shower
tap the Oracle grid and some stuff out
of storage come everything from projects
Pegasus Exodus and Goliath get ready for
a major remodel back in hardware mode
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my video all about how
Marvel is using iron man to lay the
foundation for the introduction of x-men
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
their plans have changed a couple times
along the way but a lot of these scenes
that they've recently released support
that theory so we'll break it all down
we're doing that giveaway four copies of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best Marvel
x-men Theory on the video so you've all
seen that deleted scene of Iron Man from
Iron Man 2 trying to create the new
element that powered his arc reactor
it's based on tesseract infinity stone
technology he lists up a couple of his
father's secret shield files so these
are from shields database they paid off
the project Goliath Easter Egg when we
found out about Goliath within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the character
it was the program that Hank Pym in the
Goliath character were working on when
they were both its shield trying to
create giant man back in the day I was
ex-partner on a project called
Goliath the other Easter egg project
Pegasus they just paid off during Marvel
phase 3 which was meant to set up the
tesseract the idea of the Infinity
stones and obviously then Captain Marvel
through the Marvel character project
Pegasus in that context was actually
created by Howard Stark and Marvel when
he gave her the tesseract and then built
that giant base which we then saw them
blow up at the beginning of the Avengers
movie each of the different secret
shield bosses named for a biblical major
event but also relates to some special
new technology that they were
researching or trying to create so you
don't name something with an X in it
without wanting to hint at future x-men
and originally we know what Kevin VG's
plan for introducing x-men in MU
into the MCU was because he just gave us
that deleted scene from the first Iron
Man film teasing Avengers mutants x-men
in spider-man way before we ever
actually got them in the MCU bites and
assorted mutants weren't enough I have
to deal with a spoiled brat who doesn't
play well with others and wants to keep
all his toys to himself most of you will
probably remember that one of the
biggest criticisms of Iron Man 2 in Jon
Favreau even acknowledged this is that
they were trying to use it to set up too
many future things so if they were
already trying to use it to set up all
these major concepts in the MCU the
Infinity stones the Pym particles in the
quantum realm through project Goliath
wouldn't then project Exodus be
something major that they were planning
on revealing during Marvel phase 3
Marvel phase 4 originally because it's
all about technology though that they
were developing Exodus would also have
to be some new concepts some new type of
power we've never seen before or a new
type of metal alloy that we've never
seen like adamantium if you're not a big
comic book reader adamantium was created
by accident in the comics when a
scientist working with the Avengers and
the US government tried to replicate
Hercules hammer which was made out of
something called adamantite which isn't
quite anime atiim the alloy that would
then become adamantium was created with
a combination of regular steel vibranium
which we already have now in black
panther thanks to Marvel phase 3 in an
unknown catalyst so the story concept
for what project Exodus was going to be
paying off would have been conceived
around the same time that they were
developing the story for that first
Avengers movie you have to remember that
this is all happening during Marvel
phase 1 so obviously their plans for
introducing x-men have changed a lot
because no one at that time knew that
Disney would ever buy Marvel Studios or
that then they would also buy Fox and
get all the Fox characters back they
wrote the story for Iron Man 2 in 2009
but Disney didn't buy Marvel till 2012
so it just sounds like this deleted
scene of Iron Man from Iron Man 2 was
intended to lay more groundwork to
reveal more about how the x-men and
mutant characters were originally
supposed to fit into the MCU back during
their original plan we actually know
about some of the changes he made to
that original x-men plan
because now the Eternals are sort of a
buffer between x-men coming into the MCU
it takes years to greenlight movies and
get things going so he got started on
eternals before he knew that Disney was
going to buy Fox Exodus and the Bible is
all about Moses leading the Israelites
out of Egypt Marvel could have also used
that Exodus name as code for the x-men
originally existing in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe then a grand
conspiracy put your tinfoil hats on
shield helping them vanish themselves
from sight then trying to disappear
themselves from the public consciousness
just make everyone forget about x-men if
you're a big comic book reader you
probably just read about this happening
in powers of X in house of X in the
Marvel comics it's a really easy way to
explain how x-men have been around this
whole time but we haven't heard about
them till now in Marvel phase four in
Marvel phase 5 but bringing this back
around to the Eternals what happened in
the Eternals backstory in the MCU now we
know because of recent comic book
changes that the Celestials are
indirectly responsible for creating the
X gene in x-men when the Celestials were
creating the Eternals later one came and
died on planet Earth it's celestial
blood leached into the soil that's
slowly mutated mankind's DNA to create
the X gene in fact part of the reason
why you're not seeing a whole lot of
x-men in this phase 4 schedule here
whether or not some pop up at the end
remains to be seen is because Kevin
Feige had to develop this slate in
greenlight all this stuff way before the
Fox Deal was ever done but even though
they're taking the most circuitous route
to get to those x-men characters in the
MCU
when you lay it all out Ironman is still
there as the backbone of how they lay
all this story out in fact if you look
at it the story of the MCU you could
also say is the story of the life and
death of Tony Stark but the way they
framed the Infinity Saga is that it's
all about Tony Stark going from being
this selfish guy that only cares about
himself
learning what it means to be a hero then
finally sacrificing himself for the
greater good so to speak obviously there
are a lot of theories about how he could
have survived and backed up his
consciousness there was even a deleted
scene from spider-man far from home
where he recorded a special message with
his consciousness to give to Peter that
would have originally happened when he
first saw the glasses and put them on
they later used a different voice to be
the AI of Edythe but obviously that joke
even dead I'm the hero
the joke continues into Marvel phase
four Marvel phase five even dead you can
claim that the Iron Man character is
partially responsible for the way they
introduce x-men in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the next big question you're
asking is is when are they actually
going to debut x-men characters inside
the MCU we've got in the phase four
schedule and the first couple of movies
into Phase five talking about black
panther 2 but right now the rumor is is
there's a Fantastic Four movie that's
going to debut sometime around 2022 2023
it'll take a couple years for them to
write that story but they also are
probably going to use Scarlet Witch
during The Scarlet Witch series and then
during Doctor Strange two multiverse of
madness to sort of spin that out because
there's already been canonical tie-in
books books that are canon to the MCU
that had described her as a mutant
saying that the mind stone didn't give
her powers but merely unlocked what was
already there
the reason why Marvel does stuff like
that lays Easter eggs in is to leave
themselves backdoors for storytelling
that they can exploit later on if
certain things work out but everybody
post all your project Exodus theories in
the comments below
they paid off project Pegasus they paid
off project Goliath so they're gonna pay
off project Exodus at some point in the
next couple of years if you have any
story videos or big questions that you
want me to answer in a video just let me
know in the comments below there's a new
Black Widow Thunderbolts video that I'm
working on we got some hints of possible
Thunderbolts actually happening during
the Black Widow movie so what any
giveaway winner when I post that next
Marvel video everybody click here for
that brand-new birds-of-prey trailer
video and click here for that Avengers
infinity Saga trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]